traditional caretakers of the water and
land on which we program curate educate
convene and discuss we honor and pay
respect to tongva ancestors and the
tongva community today which continues
to nurture this land and water through
traditional practices activism art and
education
we also acknowledge their continued work
to safeguard cultural resources
this is gonna sound weird
living in an artificial universe
I am fighting for everyone who felt at
one point hopeless
[Music]
now enough of that I'm I'm famished
let's eat
[Music]
life
[Music]
this is big nothing short of a miracle
question everything
world is not my
not
quite
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good evening please welcome your host
for the 49th Student Academy Awards he's
an actor author producer and incredibly
handsome and muscular please welcome to
the stage Tara
words J
thank you thank you what a room give it
up for yourself welcome
[Applause]
The Godfather In the Heat of the Night
North by Northwest think like a man I
was in the last film so
no reason to not have it in your top
five favorites
I am just so happy to be here with you
all this evening but the main reason the
main reason
is that tonight we're getting to meet
and learn about some of the best young
filmmakers and their work from around
the world this is the first year that
the competition is global meaning
there's no domestic American competition
International it's all one thing the
best of the best of the best will be
celebrated here tonight let's give it up
for that
I mean
tonight's a preview of the next 40 years
previous student Award winners include
Robert zemeckis Spike Lee uh Patricia
riggin the list goes on and on so I am
very very proud and very excited to see
some of the work that these incredible
young and up-and-coming filmmakers have
today now something that I've been
wanting to do for years is introduce the
president please welcome the president
of the academy Janet yang
Terence don't go away yet because when
you were introduced they said you were
muscular and I just you know
this one this one's tough oh that one
that hurt
I just like real evidence of you know I
want to make sure we're telling the
truth here welcome everyone I'm so
extremely pleased to be here this is one
of my first public experiences on behalf
of the Academy of Motion Pictures as
I've only been on the job for two months
but nothing feels more fitting than to
celebrate with you
each president of the academy inherits
an incredible Legacy and the legacy of
course of the Student Academy Awards is
very very large
but we don't want to just take that
Legacy and put it on a shelf like an
Oscar and look at it and go oh that's so
nice we have to renew it and you you
students who are here tonight are the
walking talking creating embodiment of
the future of filmmaker we are here to
lift you up to sustain you to encourage
you to give you a platform and to widen
the lens of our industry to ensure that
every perspective has a home right here
in the academy
so much about about the academy is
special because it's rooted in Tradition
but this year there's one major
difference that we really wanted to
acknowledge
for the very first time these awards no
longer distinguish between schools in
America and international schools as
separate categories every eligible
submission regardless of country of
origin qualifies for the competition
category the filmmaker selects
that is such good news for so many
reasons it reflects the universal truth
that films and storytelling know no
Borders or boundaries the same thread
that runs from Citizen Kane to Cinema
Paradiso to parasite to the films of
today and your films of tomorrow
are the same art is a place in the heart
and not a spot on the map
the one constant over the decades
remains simple each of you represents
the very best of student filmmaking
today
we congratulate you and we look forward
to continuing to celebrate you and your
work for decades to come
now here is a very special message from
my fellow beloved Academy Governor Eva
Duvernay thank you
hi there I'm Ava Duvernay and as a
member of the Academy's Board of
Governors I am actually thrilled to
congratulate all the nominees and
recipients of this year's Student
Academy Awards the academy established
the Student Academy Awards in 1972. that
was a long time ago that was the year I
was born okay a long time ago to support
and encourage excellence in filmmaking
at the Collegiate level those recipients
include one of my queen sugar directors
Patricia cardoso as well as Pete doctor
and Spike Lee to name only a few this
competition is unique and that it is the
only student award program in which only
Academy members vote on the films and
determine the winners so congratulations
again and I really look forward to
seeing you on set
thanks
good Candace you feeling good
today feels like draft day you guys
excited
so so now they know that they're they're
winning something today but they don't
know the order of how things are going
to go so there's still a lot of
anticipation there's still a lot of
electricity and again I know we have
people from all over the world I hear
there's five different uh countries
being represented who's here tonight
where's everybody from
where you guys not from anywhere
everybody where are you guys from tell
me
Germany is here
where else
where else
France is here with Argentina is here
all right Argentina in the back all
right where else
England and did somebody say Ohio Ohio
is not a country she said I'm from Ohio
it's far enough away we'll take it we'll
take it we will take it
well listen let's get this show on the
road right now it is an honor to
introduce the creator of Trevor a short
film that literally saved lives and
sparked a movement now we remember this
short film because of the vision and
human touch that defines the work of the
chair of the Student Academy Awards
executive committee please welcome
Academy Award winner Peggy ricekey
hey everybody I'm so happy to be here
and thank you thank you Terence
you know films are both complicated and
simple
complicated because of all the
ingredients that have to be combined to
tell a story authentically
they're simple in that they all have one
thing in common they're a form of
Storytelling that can make you care
and that was true of the story of 13
year old trouble Trevor in the film I
directed
and it's true of all the work that each
of our
1796 student filmmakers shared with us
this year
this exactly
this extraordinary assembly of upcoming
Talent came from 614 schools in 75
different countries they represent the
next generation of Industry talent and
our beautiful reminder that film is for
everyone everywhere
each film came from the heart
and they put it on film for all 627
Academy member judges to see and feel
for themselves
I think that act of creative courage
makes all of our entrants winners
and to those 627 judges who generously
gave their time our deepest appreciation
we couldn't do any of this without you
[Applause]
and to my fellow members of on the
Student Academy Awards executive
committee you have my heartfelt respect
and gratitude for all the time you spend
making sure this program is as strong
and inclusive as it can be
many of these members are with us in the
theater tonight so please join me in
giving them a round of applause thank
you
have a stand
[Applause]
and a big congratulations to this year's
winners I can't wait to see you again
next year at the Student Academy Awards
big 50th anniversary
and while we're looking forward to next
year's big anniversary I do want to take
a moment to look back
our 2020 and 2021 Student Academy Award
winners won their Awards in the midst of
a life-altering pandemic
while we did celebrate virtually they
did not get an in-person ceremony
fortunately some of those students are
here with us tonight
so please we're bringing up on the slide
our 2020 winners and I'd love the folks
that are here to please stand when I
call your name
there's
Skylar porus
Allison Wade
Marin gluckhead
[Applause]
I ran into her in the restroom
and now for 2021
Simon Dundon
denda
Kristen Wang and me Lou gevers and
Christy hoy
you hear Diana Young and Stevens there
we're so glad you could be here
and I also want to say
um that I'm so glad we've given them the
Applause they truly deserve and now
Terence I think it's time we hand out
this year's Awards enjoy
so much
all right you heard the chairwoman
let's begin with the animation category
now in order to get into this category I
need everybody to do something I need
you to close your eyes
I want you to think back to when you
were three years old six years old eight
years old
and you first walked into that darkens
movie theater and you smelled that
popcorn
and whoever brought you out to the
theater
took it was it yeah let the lights dim
good production value here tonight
I love it
you remember when ever when you first
saw Peter Pan fly
when you first saw the story of Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs I mean for me
it was The Lion King I love Simba so
much that I made my dad hold me over the
bathtub or I wouldn't I wouldn't get in
it
hey yeah
hey that visual was a lot isn't it
that's too much
but just think about what animation
means to all of us and for many of us
our very first movies were animated now
this year's student winners
are in the art form see she's crying
right now because she's like yeah you're
right
these student winners have perfected the
art form pixel by pixel to create the
next movie moments to inspire and emote
now before we take a look at this year's
winning films and the filmmakers who
made them you need some background all
of these filmmakers being honored
tonight know that their Student Academy
Award winners but last month they all
joined on a zoom it was a secret Zoom
where they thought they were just going
to be interviewed but they were
surprised by an amazing accomplished
filmmaker to reveal their win now the
students like I said earlier they do not
know which medal they won tonight
whether it's gold silver or bronze we
will be letting them know right here in
front of all of you this evening all
right so what I want you to do is time
to check out our animation winners take
a look
I've invited a filmmaker to join our
conversation oh um he's a producer and
director who's been nominated for the
best animated feature film Oscar three
times well guys I'd like you to meet Tom
Moore oh wow
hi guys
congratulations I'm really happy to be
able to tell you that you have indeed
won a student Academy Award and uh well
done well done what
okay um no
um okay uh
our film is about Nemo a deep sea diver
who's the only one in his Coastal
Village with a huge helmet until he
meets a girl from a foreign country
which is like an astronaut Nemo is a
character that I could really relate to
because he was his helmet which is a
shield to the outside but also a good
way to hide inside I think because of
the whole time more important it's a
story of our isolation and there come a
person to help you come out of the of
this of this situation and I think
very much people will need this person
and not only on the personal level it's
also like an international phenomenon
that countries and states and cultures
tend to isolate and still there are
like-minded people around the world and
if you overcome isolation you can find
familiar things in foreign appearances
it's just you know we win the Student
Academy Awards yeah we're in the whole
team we want it as a team it's a very
good stepping stone I think to go
further to follow this path and I think
there are many stories to tell and very
interesting characters to to develop
Lachlan I'd love you to meet Tom Moore
good to meet you sir your film is just
fantastic I absolutely loved it my
congratulations because I'm able to tell
you that you've won the Student Academy
Award what yeah that's well done thanks
so much
my film is about a office worker who is
not very good at their job and is slowly
realizing that they're in a stop-motion
Animated Universe does that sound right
oh
it comes from I guess a place of of just
loving the behind the scenes of
stop-motion filmmaking and the craft of
it and so I
wanted to come up with a story that
could really showcase all that sort of
like you're watching the film being made
at the same time as watching the film
stop motion has something very special
very different to other mediums and I
think a lot of it for me is in the
tactile sort of handmade qualities
that's so ingrained into the Aesthetics
I think the one thing that I would love
the audience to take away from this film
is I guess that Wonder of Animation that
harks back to like the origins of film
in a way of just being able to recreate
a life with a series of images is you
know wondrous question everything young
man the world is not quite what it seems
there's that sort of pressure I guess
now like what's the next film you know
it's sort of just keep keep going keep
doing getting better and I think just
with winning the award people are
starting to notice me and reach out to
me and that's that's really cool
foreign
I'm very happy to meet you I saw your
movie in them in Morocco actually at
mcness Festival and I thought it was
really really special so I'm really
honored that I can tell you that you
guys have won the Student Academy Award
so congratulations
we were already surprised that by every
step so knowing this and we weren't
expecting it of course it's like insane
is a 3D animation short movie from the
virtually school which talks about the
night of 1961 in October in Paris in
France this night the RGN got on the
street to manifest in that the mandatory
cashew that between the police
perfection
we try to give another end to the story
baby
personally I
had to say something about these events
because it's an event that creates a lot
of associations in France that is a
traumatic for a lot of people I think
one of the main objective when we work
on this film is we want The Spectator
after the projection go to internet and
search this event we also want to to
show that there is another way to see
how to live in community a more fresh
way let's say we don't have to forget
the past but with the thinking of the
past we can build a better way to live
together yeah Community where everyone
can be together without any problem
winning this award for us is just a
dream a dream it might be the greatest
honor you can earn as shopping makers
and I think for us it's just the start I
hope
[Music]
foreign
how amazing I mean just seeing those
clips you can tell how incredible those
films are right
wow and we have a very special surprise
all the way from Ireland please welcome
Tom Moore
what's up how you feeling man I'm pretty
good I'm pretty honored and happy to be
here I'm happy to be here with my dad
and some friends so it's pretty exciting
and uh where's your dad at he's out
there somewhere what's up hey Dad
what's up man but listen I'm a little
bit jet-lagged I came all the way from
Ireland so I let you start and I'll just
help out is that okay turn tag teams
together all right thanks man all right
okay all right so what are uh so many
remarkable entries in this category
please give it up for this year's Bronze
Award winner for animation and let's
bring out these Awards
and now Tom before we give out these
Awards these are very heavy Awards
here's a fun fact for you the Oscar the
academy award trophy is eight and a half
pounds and these Awards right here let
me see this these
are eight and a half pounds as well so
as you get these you're one step closer
all right you'll feel the weight you'll
feel it okay please welcome and give it
up for the Bronze Award winner for
animation yanis belaid
Elliot Bernard and Nicola mayor
for the same tears
[Applause]
congratulations
[Applause]
hello everyone
thank you for this award it's such a
Organization for the for the artwork and
the love we put in this project
first of all we want to thank of course
the the academy for this beautiful week
in La of course and um uh for the night
too and I want to thanks her family to
support us for so long
um years
we've been really lucky to be surrounded
but amazing people that Believe in Us
and make us achieve the best impossible
for us which I would like to thank the
poultry team that is here invest tonight
so if you could give them a round of
applause
over there
and we are we are also really happy that
the film is being seen and appreciated
all around the world so thank you very
much
obviously we can thank the five other
members of our team that are around with
us today in these are still in France
um
it's a one of the greatest award we can
receive as directors so once again
thank you thank you very much thank you
well done guys congratulations and
please welcome this year's silver Award
winner for animation Jan gatherman and
Sebastian gado for Leica and Nemo
[Applause]
okay wow
hey come on
[Applause]
oh uh what an honor you see it's a big
big team and this is not all of us so it
might take a while
we want to thank the academy of course
and all its members
after all we've been through together
um it's been such an honor to be
standing here today to share this story
of of Nemo um who is not accepted for
being a little different than everybody
else
um a topic that always has been relevant
and still is today yeah um to be
different can also be a good thing and
sometimes you find something familiar
and unknown
and together as a team you can move
mountains
uh it can be a heart it can be hard
sometimes but it is worth the effort
even if it takes you six and a half
years like us yeah
so why
we're so glad that so many of our teams
are here with us today and a big shout
out
um Joshua Dominic Barbara Georg Maya
Vincent engines
yes
Sebastian Sanchez Martin Herald and
conusco yeah
and of course many thanks to the ones
who can cannot be here today Luke has
called
um Martin and of course Johannes
Schubert
and all our supporters all over the
world
um of course the film University
bubblesberg for letting us do is do this
for so long
um our head of Animation Christina
Schindler who fought for us many times
our funders the median board Berlin
Brandenburg and the broadcaster Airbnb
um and to our our dear friends at
McKinnon Saunders who supported us from
very early on
also thank you very much to uhkabitz if
we
um we we missed you sorry
we miss you girl
um then of course uh special thanks to
my parents for the support to my
siblings my friends and my idols to
Philip and Schnitz
and all who made me who I am today and
um
sorry
and of course my wonderful girlfriend
Lina
and
I get through this um
he did this yes I'm so excited we will
be a family soon
and
and finally from my side
um best regards to the stop-motion scene
in Germany and everywhere keep on doing
what you do
yeah
special thanks to my family and friends
I think my mom Sabine to be my mom and
my brother Daniel my wonderful wife
Stephanie gato and my two child children
Lydia and Phil uh
I love you so much and yeah I thank
Micha and Peter Garo thank you thank you
Reina and my many thanks to the student
instruction Focus for your support and
thank you all and last but not least
thank you the academy thank you so much
thank you it's been marvelous
thank you
little man was fresh to death
had his suit
and you saw your man he uh he shouted
out his girlfriend the other guy had to
come back I like to thank my wife had to
make sure he didn't want to miss that
moment I'm sitting there backstage my
girlfriend been sinola she's like see
he's been up there for 10 seconds and
shot his girlfriend out where's my shout
out hey baby I'm sorry I'm sorry gonna
got all of us in trouble with that shout
out everybody started all all the wives
in the building started clapping see
that's how you're supposed to do it
see thank you all right I'm proud to
introduce this year's Gold Medal winner
for animation please welcome to the
stage and congratulations to Lachlan
Pendragon
for an ostrich told me the world is fake
and I think you believe it
congratulations
[Applause]
um hello
um uh yes this is amazing thank you so
much to the academy thank you to all the
academy members for the support
um this is such an honor um I have I
want to really thank every single like
Mentor or teacher and supervisor that
I've had over the years from my high
school students at the high high school
teacher sorry
um who you know encouraged me to take
this seriously as a as a potential
career and you know to my uh University
uh teachers who've guided me and given
me a lot of advice uh to the my
supervisors on this film uh Peter Moyes
and Louise Harvey thank you so much back
in Australia thank you very much to them
um and uh yeah thank you to Griffith
film school where I produced this film
um and yes thank you very much it's been
an amazing week uh and I hope it's been
amazing to spend time with some
incredible filmmakers uh who you know
enjoy doing this is just as much as I do
it's been a great week thank you to the
academy uh thank you looking forward to
meeting more of you uh tonight thank you
thank you
Lachlan Pendragon took time away from
the set of Game of Thrones to be here
tonight so uh I love that name I want to
change my name to Lachlan picture can I
be like because if they see a black guy
walking he's locking up in Dragon
talk to your family see if we can work
something out I want to be part of the I
want to be part of the Terence pen
Dragon it's how I want to be introduced
my friend I love it
congrats and uh where Tom just left me
Tom thank you so much for your help um
what an exciting category thank you all
and please give it up for all of our
student winners so far what a nice
all right
time for our second category it is
alternative experimental films and what
could be more exciting than marching to
the beat of Your Own Drum and creating
something that's utterly new and
different the beauty of film is that
every generation gets its chance to
reinvent itself
the old lines are done it's time to
explore reimagination is another word
for alternative so what I want you to do
right now is sit back and just enjoy
this snapshot of how this year's student
winner reimagines the craft Tom there
you go Tom all right Tom is back uh you
can help me out with this one as well
sure sure all right best looking guy in
I got to make sure he's close by me okay
let's take a look at this next category
it will be I'd love you to meet Tom
Moore Hi how are you hello I'm great
Olivia really a pleasure such a lovely
thing to be able to tell you that you've
won the gold medal the Student Academy
Award oh my God thank you
good day
my name's Olivia peace I went to the
University of Southern California and my
film is called against reality
against reality is the story of why I
decided to teach myself how to lucid
dream and it's made using AI I'm an
animator so I was thinking it was going
to be some sort of Animation that's when
I saw AI generated art on Tick Tock and
on Twitter I hit up literally one of the
tick tockers to teach me
I taught myself the technology some of
the programming language and the film
itself was born there wasn't real
education around it there wasn't real
theory around it even if I ran into a
roadblock I would pop on Discord hop on
Reddit and people literally from all
over the world would be in the assist
boards trying to help troubleshoot I
always love that sort of a challenge I'm
always down to learn something new if
it's going to serve the idea and a
really impactful way in the end the
actual crew for this film is literally
me my friend Justin who did all the
sound design and the AI which I guess in
a way it's like everyone who's ever
uploaded something to the internet
this film can be a proof of concept for
a whole different style of Animation
really so I think when it comes to
filmmaking we're still at the very
beginning of what film can do winning
the Student Academy Award means a lot to
me because it means a lot to the people
who have been up list thingy and
supporting me throughout this process
that puts me in conversation with
filmmakers that I really admire
hopefully more people will want to
support what we're doing in the future
because it's only getting bigger and
bigger
[Applause]
I'm so inspired right now please welcome
this year's winner of the category of
alternative experimental Olivia Pierce
for against reality
congratulations
oh my God it is really heavy
um
uh hello so first I want to thank the
academy for making space for work that
is alternative
the places where I come from encourage
and inspire me to move a little
differently to find alternative ways of
viewing the worlds and Creative
Solutions to seemingly unsolvable
problems so I honor the black indigenous
and queer ancestors and living thought
leaders whose rigor and audacity allows
my work to exist
I owe everything to loving the
ecosystems that I come from
to Justin Enoch my friend and sound
designer thanks for swooping down and
lending your Brilliance to this project
and building this world with me
to my beloved Community my family my
team my department at USC and of course
my friends and neighbors it is an honor
to be able to rep the set tonight
uh no one stands on any stage alone We
Are All Made of and changed by
everything we come in contact with
and I'm so grateful that all of that
change LED us here today
so thank you
all right thank you again Tom thank you
so much and congratulations
now a few genres have changed more in
the last decades than the fields of
documentary filmmaking they've changed
the look the technique the attitude and
the perspective they bring important
truths to life and they hold a powerful
account of the most vulnerable voices
that is the impact of documentary
filmmaking in this year's winning
filmmakers do just that sharing the news
was multiple NAACP image Award winner
and the director of Emmy nominated
documentary becoming and the 2022 film
on Ben Crump civil director and
cinematographer Nadia Hal Green
let's take a look
I'd like to introduce you to Nadia
halgren hello
nice to meet you too how you doing today
very good congratulations on being a
finalist I'm actually here to share
another piece of news with you your film
is a winner of the Student Academy Award
wow
wow I didn't prepare for it
thank you
my documentary found is about a kid who
was kidnapped 12 years ago and last year
he was found and his first father wants
him back but unfortunately he was raised
by adopted parents so it's meaning a
story about the conflict and the tense
between the birth father and adopted
parents
foreign
I found that there are many stories
about how the bird's parents trying to
find these kids uh who are kidnapped but
actually there's only a few or no story
about when the kiss was found because I
found the story of the found is more
more cruel and worse to be recorded the
tricky part is I want to film The both
sides to let the audience to think about
who is wrong or who is right to judge
the situation by themselves we
documentaries are using our cameras to
capture the precious moment and the
moment is in our SD card and it creates
an unforgettable memory and the memory
is so precious and critical to our lives
I just wish I could keep filming
documentary in the next five years I got
a chance to win the Student Academy new
world can help me to doing another
project in the future that's my goal
hey Jared
hi there it's an honor to meet you well
I'm very
tell you that
your film has won a student Academy
Award
I'm oh my God thank you wow I'm
completely speechless and alone in my
apartment but this is crazy there is no
Pro like
choice so here to stay is a short
documentary that follows the political
campaign of Giselle Martinez who's a 23
year old first generation mexican-americ
woman who runs for office in Newburgh
New York which is one of the most
dangerous cities in America so this film
really hits home for me for a variety of
reasons I live about 20 minutes away
from Newburgh I grew up my whole life
not knowing about Newberg so learning
about that you know neighbors 20 minutes
away from me are living below the
poverty line and are dealing with this
violent crime was definitely one thing
but I think on the other side of things
Giselle just has a subject I think we're
living during a time where there's a lot
of bad news and Gisele is someone who
shows us that we can lean into it and we
can work together to solve it we don't
have to run away from it we won the
Student Academy Award
[Music]
are you serious I'm an artist who
operates uh by learning from others and
to be able to join the Student Academy
award-winning community of filmmakers
will allow me to continue to work that
way on an even bigger scale I think it
all comes down to empathy that when the
credits scroll that people feel that
they have a greater sense of empathy
stories that shine a light on diverse
communities and diverse voices those are
the kinds of films I think we need and
those are the kinds of films that we
need to make
hi Gabriella hi Michael hi yes oh my
goodness I've seen you on screen
that's crazy and actually have some news
to share with you this morning your film
has won a student Academy Award
wow I honestly don't know how I'm gonna
do the rest of my day now
our short documentary seasons is about a
family-run farm in New Jersey told
Through The Eyes of an immigrant mother
and her young daughter as they struggle
to carry on his legacy I was originally
interested in telling a story about land
stewardship and immigrant farmers and no
Farmers really wanted to talk with me so
as a last resort I went to a farmers
market it was the last farmer that I
spoke with said yes and that was nephew
when I met nevia and saw Bodhi Tree Farm
I was
blown away because they live so
harmoniously with their land and with
the seasons and it just felt like an
incredibly compelling story that I
wanted to tell my whole life someone
always had a camcorder on them tell me
these really intimate moments until
someone finally passed the camcorder
into my own hand and it felt really
right this is what I want to continue to
do it's like preserving these moments so
that we all just kind of share I grew up
with an autistic brother you know he was
seemingly a pretty happy healthy kid but
you know kind of behind the scenes there
were a lot of challenges and a lot of
you know kind of scary moments these
experiences have put me in a great
position to tell stories about people
who are facing invisible challenges in
their lives winning a student Academy
Award is unreal it's honestly just a
justification of all the time the
craftsmanship that went into making our
film we're honored you know we're
honored to be in this position I hope
that when audiences watch our film that
they recognize that there are folks out
there demonstrating very healthy ways to
engage with the natural world basically
I hope people walk away from our film
wanting to thank their local farmers and
hug their mothers
foreign
now as you saw from all of the
highlights all three of these filmmakers
brought us stories that needed to be
told please welcome our bronze medal
winner for documentary
Gabriella canal and Michael farran for
seasons
hey
um uh thank you first of all thank you
to the academy for this incredible
opportunity uh we're amongst incredible
filmmakers it's just such an honor to
share our work
um thank you to Bodhi Tree Farm for
sharing the most vulnerable aspects of
their lives with us and for feeding our
communities you guys always amaze us
thank you to my family my brother my mom
my dad who are here and the rest of my
family for always believing in me and
supporting me and for being my very
first film Muses as you all saw
and my partner Brendan for being here
every step of the way of making this
film you inspire me and last of all just
want to thank all the women in my family
who came before me those who may have
stepped into roles they never wanted to
thank you for showing me how to listen
to my heart and I make films because of
you
that was great
um documentary filmmaking can be
extremely challenging at times and there
were a lot of people who encouraged us
and supported us when things inevitably
got tough and uh we'd like to thank
everyone at Columbia University graduate
school of Journalism our teachers and
advisors and fellow students who you
know continued to push us and ask
questions and encourage us just to
continue to probe and and search further
and
um I'd also like to thank my family for
providing an amazing place to grow up an
amazing household and I'd like to thank
Holly Gibson and August Gibson fearon
for being by my side the entire step of
the way for this film so thank you and
wait
in true dark fashion
okay
congratulations once again now our
silver metal goals in the category of
documentary goals
to Jared peralia for here to stay
[Applause]
um thank you so much and thank you so
much to the academy it feels very
strange saying that
um just want to say uh first of all
thank you to these amazing uh four
people up here with me who I completely
share this with uh Gisele Martinez
Samantha Garcia Nicholas muhart and
ireli Webb like this I share this with
you
first of course have to thank uh Gisele
Martinez
um who this film will not be possible
without your story continues to inspire
me uh Inspire everyone in this room so
thank you to you your family and the
people of Newburgh it's a beautiful
place
um I got to thank New York University to
school the Arts uh Alice Elliott and
David bagnall in particular uh who
advised this film and guided it through
from inception to uh right here right
now
um and of course have to thank my mom my
dad and my sister Julia thank you so
much
foreign
congratulations
now this year's Gold Medal winner for
documentary is
shayao say for found
now
unfortunately the director couldn't
travel to be here with us today but his
composer Cal fruitlick is here with us
to accept on his behalf and I'm sorry if
I mispronounced that
hope I got that right
close enough
hi everyone my name is Cal freundlick
I'm the composer on this film
um I'm really honored to be representing
shuhau and he gave me a few words to
read to you all uh he said I would like
to say thank you most to my character
Tong and his family thank you for
trusting me and generously sharing this
period of your tough life with me and my
camera
having the opportunity to accompany you
and your family is much more important
than finishing found making
documentaries is like an art of trust
the trust is so precious to me and I'll
treat it carefully forever
from your story I hope that we will have
more comprehension
of this complex world and more
understanding of each other
though I cannot be here with you today I
believe tonight is just a start like
what Johnny Cash wrote in his lyrics I
know we'll meet again I know we'll meet
again some sunny day
it's not only the best wish for all of
us but also the best wish for tongue and
his son show how you deserve this
congratulations
[Applause]
hi everyone this is your housee I really
want to say thank you to the academy
giving me and my fumes such a great
opportunity to be involved in this
fantastic film award
unfortunately this time I cannot be here
with you but I really wish you have a
great week and hope you enjoy my film
found thank you
all right now it's time for the final
category of the evening narrative
this simple definition of narrative is a
spoken or written account of connected
events if only you're that easy tonight
we celebrate the brilliant and inspired
connectors who turn words into feelings
into something bigger than all of us a
story that compels and captures our
hearts and Imagination
to give them the news of their award was
an accomplished filmmaker known for
directing films like Love and Basketball
The Secret Life of Bees and most
recently the woman King please check out
this video with Gina Prince Blackwood
take a look
[Applause]
hello hi hello hi how does it feel to be
a finalist in the Student Academy Awards
I remember the moment immediately my
heart started to beat very fast when we
got the news we had to celebrate
probably for a week so there's another
part of this interview that I didn't
mention in the email one would be a
little surprise I've invited the
filmmaker to join us I'd like to
introduce you to Gina Prince bike with
Hello nice to meet you hi nice to meet
you such an honor
it's my pleasure to tell you that you
have won a student Academy Award
congratulations thank you so much
[Laughter]
I studied at the University for
television and film in Munich almost
home is a mix of coming of age genre and
Science Fiction it's a story of a mother
and her son who've been traveling
through space they really want to get
off the spaceship but unfortunately they
get to know that there is a pandemic
it's an amazing astonishing thing that
people might see something that has been
imprisoned as like a safe place to be
I was creatively influenced a lot by my
father he was connected to the film
business in a musical way and I feel
like doing the process I always have a
chance to have like musicality the
editing the sound design the details
I think for me as a filmmaker winning a
student Academy Award it feels like a
very important step filmmakers can
create situations where they they're
voicing things they can't put in words
or realities that are far from the
audience but then very close really
helps us to reflect ourselves like as a
society and talk about scenarios that we
are going through Student Academy Award
Governor
winning the Student Academy Awards it's
a big boost because it gives a
credibility I'm looking forward to the
future
hey wolf how are you I I get to be the
one to tell you that you are a student
Academy Award winner congratulations wow
I also couldn't believe it right now
my name is verif I study at University
of television and film in Munich my
movie rooms is about an elderly couple
who somehow managed to stay in love and
and that need to fight for his love now
against the threat of an eviction I
started my research with the Munich
district court and they allowed me to
witness three real evictions in Germany
housing is a human right what I want the
audience to take from this movie to the
buildings how easily you can get in a
situation where you need to fear about
losing your home and how existential it
can be all the movies that I want to do
in the future will have that realism to
tell stories about people who can't tell
their own
winning a student Academy Award has
always been my dream when I started
studying I had printed out a picture of
it to my wall to motivate me
[Music]
I want to thank all the people being
involved in this project and to tell
this particular story in our way I'm
really thankful but
hey nice to meet you you are a student
Academy Award winner oh my God you guys
are gonna make me cry this is bad
because it's filming my name is Freddie
MacDonald and I went to the American
Film Institute shedding Angels is a
story about a young man who lives for
the annual costume party at his local
bar one day he stumbles upon this
elderly widow's yard sale and he finds
the perfect costume there and steals
them without her knowing he wins the
contest but on his drunken stumble home
he bumps into the Widow and for the next
several days plays the role of her dead
spouse I knew you weren't ready
the story was inspired by this video I
found online of the street dancer this
costume with two dummies in front of him
and two dummies behind him and he was
connected by PVC and when he walked the
dummies walked with him in perfect sink
and I thought what a better tool to use
in a film both visually and thematically
the film is incredibly personal to me it
was written during the pandemic I felt
incredibly stuck as well as my
collaborators we wanted to tell a story
about two people who are stuck who find
each other in a strange way and are
brought together in that sense ever
since I was nine years old my dad has
taught me everything he used to run an
animation studio and I discovered all of
his leftover gear I spent hours
animating puppets frame by frame even
though I shoot in live action now I
really want to touch everything on set I
just really like having a Hands-On
approach we won
winner
isn't that crazy
so you should you should be so happy
filmmaking is incredibly important
because it can expose people to
different worlds and different
characters and hopefully bring them
together because of it my ultimate goal
as a director is just to keep on
directing it if I can continue to
produce original content that is my
dream and I'm gonna fight as hard as I
can to do that
foreign
I need one of those costumes with this
walk around ready for Halloween with
that man
the bronze winner for narrative
Freddie McDonald for shedding Angels now
he's unable to be here with us tonight
he's in the middle of directing his
first independent feature film but
huge but members of his team are here to
accept this award on his behalf please
welcome to the stage
[Applause]
hello hello
[Applause]
well I wasn't sure if we were going to
space Beach because of Freddy being uh
he's gonna do the speech but I just want
you to introduce of course absolutely
well we've got this uh we'll start with
over here we've got Keegan Roberson he
is our costume designer
Rafael Diaz our writer
rui archiga our cinematographer
[Applause]
and volume about is our uh sorry
production designer
and Jessica Peterson our editor
and
I'm the producer hi we're here because
Freddy is actually this is the day he's
rapping and uh he's in Switzerland and
that's why he's not here but he's
actually here up here to talk to you so
Freddie let's hear from you
huge thank you to the academy for this
incredible honor I wish more than
anything I could be there in person but
I'm currently shooting my first feature
in Switzerland and today is our last day
of shooting so I hope my collaborators
are on stage right now Alex rui Jessica
and Bonnie and Raphael without you guys
believing in this crazy bizarre story it
would have never been made huge thank
you to Calum Worthy MK Callan for
starring in this piece and elevating it
with your perfect performances I also
have to thank everyone at AFI the AFI
faculty uh Harrison James uh Laura James
Adam salkey Andrew Wagner and Julian
Higgins thank you for accepting me to
AFI in the first place and letting me
make this project I'd also like to
lastly thank UTA Rich glue back in
Amanda Heim some for your guidance
shedding Angels is a story about two
unlikely people coming together in a
very bizarre way and in a world that is
incredibly divided this story breaking
up you're more relevant in showing how
these unlikely people can grow and
accept one another despite their
differences so thank you Academy and I
really appreciate it
thank you
guys so much congratulations
[Applause]
now we are proud to share that shedding
Angels is also the first student film to
receive a student green seal from the
environmental media Association that
means that during the production of that
film they recycled they reuse they did
everything environmentally friendly and
run a new category award for that so
congratulations for that
as we all strive to go green that is
very very important now the silver Medal
winner for narrative
Is wealth Reinhardt for rooms
congratulations
[Applause]
in research for this movie I had the
chance to follow a bailiff to three real
evictions
one of them was pretty close on what you
have seen in our movie
and when I was standing there unable to
help and only watching
I felt incredibly guilty
then I realized that watching is
probably the best thing we all can do
I want to thank the academy for this
amazing honor and for their hard work
it's really an honor
to receive this award as a team because
filmmaking is and always will be a team
sport
[Applause]
I want to thank my male main actor
thank you
I want to thank my male main actor
Reinhardt fish and friend who passed
away this year
thank you for your time
and I want to thank my other main actor
Ingrid Farin for all her energy and
passion
it's truly been an honor working with
the two of you
find it
finally I want to thank all my crew and
cast members the University of
television and film our co-production
partners and the many many supporters
thank you for all your hard work
for your sweat and tears because making
this movie wasn't easy especially during
covid
but we made it and we made something
great to a very important topic on which
I would like to remind us all one more
time with this final statement
statistically in this room no matter if
you're young or old or from Germany or
the us at least 10 people will be forced
to leave their home at one point in
their life
so we should never forget that this
affects us all and that adequate housing
is a human right
thank you
how exciting to be here tonight our
friends came all the way from Germany
friends from France France from all over
Argentina this is an incredible night
and it's time for our Gold Medal winner
uh and since I'm inspired by him I'm
going to pass this around to everybody
in the audience
now this year's Gold Medal winner for
narrative
is Niels Keller for almost home
[Music]
congratulations
thank you very much
[Applause]
yes please the whole team come up here
would fall off
no
all right
yeah
um hello wow this feels like Inception
actually it's like a dream inside a
dream and yeah I don't know how many
dreams there are but yeah thank you to
the academy for this incredible honor
my deepest gratitude goes out to my
fiance Pamela who's here tonight with my
parents when I told them that my dream
was to become a filmmaker funny enough
they didn't kick me out the door but
instead they they supported me in
believing in my dreams and um sort of
pardon me all the way
even though it wasn't always easy
thanks a lot for that I love you
[Applause]
thank you to the amazing team and all
the incredible supporters who all
deserve part of this award and without
whom this wouldn't have been possible
first those who are here tonight
Nicolaus the GOP Jonas leimberg the
producer Carolina Oswald the line
producer Max Richard one of my oldest
and best friends and massively important
to this film
yeah the editor and by the way my
brother
Philip Robert and the rest of the lihof
production team thank you so much for
sharing this dream with me and thanks
for your trust it's amazing thanks
[Applause]
now the people that are not here tonight
the actors hiramia Suzanne Stefan
Patricia Malaya and also from the team
and supporters Lucas Nana pan Hans I'm
trying not to forget any name here
Miriam lilit Clara Moritz Stefan Andrew
Sebastian Joachim Kruger Maya Julia van
Heins
the University of Television of film
Munich which supported me all those
years thank you so much
German films and so so many others and
not to forget my future parents-in-law
I'm already reaching the two minutes
here trust is an amazing thing it's
magical this film wouldn't have been
possible without it we had little money
an ongoing pandemic we wanted no we
needed to build a full-scale walkable
spaceship
tons of visual effects so many things
could have gone wrong
but in the end our Dream didn't crash it
started flying
funny enough in the end our film itself
is about the ability to stay optimistic
and Trust even when we Face hard
challenges in life so yeah
let's keep on trusting each other
let's keep on dreaming together
because as you can see great things can
happen from there
thank you so much to the academy
thank you
congrats congrats
congratulations thank you
wow
what a night give it up for all of our
winners this evening
so powerful
I'm so moved so much talent has walked
across this stage tonight now before we
wrap things up I'd like to introduce
Academy vice president of talent
development and inclusion programs
Kendra Carter and the senior director of
inclusion analytics and awards Sean
Guthrie please welcome them to the stage
here she goes
thank you Terence everybody give it up
for Terence one more time
doing a great job tonight
congratulations to all of our winners uh
and a quick shout out to our trophy
presenters miracle and coma and shuben
gonzalea for our interns from our goal
Rising program
I'm honored to be working at the Academy
on programs to not only discover and
nurture and do an exciting Talent uh and
voices but also invest in the future of
film our mission is to help open doors
for aspiring filmmakers to explore their
Futures in the industry and I thank each
of you and our Academy members for
supporting this important effort as we
continue to develop new Talent
and now I'll turn it over to The Man
Behind the Scenes who makes things fun
and makes my job easier Sean Guthrie
thank you Kendra
it's always nice to hear appreciation
and I actually came out here because I
wanted to thank the people who make my
job easier and keep the Student Academy
Awards on track and on time
Hector Garcia and Chris Zampino
thank you for being an awesome crew
these Awards and tonight's event would
not be possible without you
and speaking of Cruz tonight's
filmmakers have a few more words to say
on the topic themselves
filmmaking is a team sport and that's
why I really need to thank a lot of
people could you write them down to not
forget anybody yeah
[Music]
Justin Enoch who did all the sound
design all the composition I've never
heard anything like this one of the tech
guys at the film School James anytime I
would need something I would go to him
and be like oh I need to get some gear
before the film school locks up for
covert for like months and it's like oh
okay uh okay quick get here and I'll
I'll sort you out first and foremost I
think Samantha Garcia she really was my
lifeline and then I'd have to say thank
you to Nicholas muhart who really wore
many many hats as you do when making a
documentary film I want to say some
thank you to my photographer Jin and
pong Chen they not only do the shooting
process to help me to communicate with
this first father and adopted parents
this film would not have been possible
without Alex my producer he was the
first person to read my pitch and he saw
the gem and the craziness of the initial
draft the visual effects guy his name is
Lucas feet there's a lot of visual
effects shots you wouldn't even know
about because it it's just like space
for example but there's some work in
putting the space there we'd also like
to thank our audio post team at Splash
NYC uh
[Music]
they were really important in the making
of the films I want to thank also my dop
Matthias but also the screenwriter
attender which also did a great job a
year before we started shooting
researching and writing with me our post
team Manny Arroyo Elizabeth Phillips and
Weiner and young woo and last but not
least our wonderful puppet maker Martin
Walker who stayed with us for two years
yes and of course everybody who helped
and supported us at the film University
over the many years we were in
production to sum it up I want to thank
a lot of people and I'm really thankful
for you helping me to tell this
particular story and I couldn't be more
thankful
thank you
what an honor to be here this evening I
am so happy that Ryan Seacrest was
unavailable tonight was just one of
those magical magical nights I want to
give a big congratulations to all of the
winners past and present let's give them
one more round of applause
you all have created something that's so
impressive and we're looking forward to
see what you accomplish in the years to
come as you're here please make sure to
take in this incredible space the
academy is celebrating 95 years this
award show is celebrating 49 years but
this museum has just celebrated its
first birthday so you guys are some of
the first people in here to enjoy this
beautiful space take a look at this
beautiful red seats in this this place
is magical right
so please enjoy this space while you're
here thank you so much for your time and
for everybody that worked behind the
scenes to make tonight possible and each
and every one of you for attending it's
a thrill to be here with you and welcome
back to all of our gold medal winners
please uh come up to the stage at the
end of the program we're going to take a
group photo with all of you together and
of course at the end we're going to be
screening all of the gold medal winning
films they will begin so anybody that
wants to watch those incredible pieces
of work you'll be able to sit here and
enjoy it in this magical theater and
watch it as well on behalf of my friends
at the Academy my name is Terence J
thank you so much for coming God bless
and have a good night
let's go